winter is coming it starting to feel
like a reunion Game of Thrones season 6
episode 6 blood of my blood this is your
reminder that i do not do spoiler free
reviews anymore let's get right into it
so lots of characters we haven't seen in
a while popping up starting right off
the bat with Benjen stark saving brand
and I'm sorry I forget her name but the
girl who's with him and even though they
would not reveal that it was benjin
until the end of the episode I pretty
much called that as soon as he showed up
I didn't call how it was he happened to
still be alive that so that was
interesting to find out that's not
nothing although we don't see him we get
a few more details on the blackfish and
what he's up to and in finding out more
about that we see Walder Frey for the
first time in a while it's kind of nice
seeing him again if only because I'm
hoping that they're reestablishing him
so maybe they can kill him mmm so
jumping back for saying the other thing
that was interesting about the opening
was seeing that brand kind of had like
an info dump into his head from the
three-eyed Raven he saw all sorts of
stuff that he hasn't seen before some of
which stuff we haven't seen before which
was really cool i really love arias
scenes i first of all they did with her
what I wanted her to happen that her
conscious is too strong to just be a
killer for money she has to have a
reason to want to kill somebody so I was
very happy to see her have that change
of heart but i think they build up to a
nicely with her watching this play and
watching this actress but also sort of
see even though it's this sort of second
hand and pastiche representation of a
but see the pain of losing family which
is a pain she knows just to watch all
that resonating just see the gears
turning she portrays all that very well
and he gots when she got a needle out
from those rocks oh that was great now i
am a little bit nervous for her but i'm
also excited because that other girl
looks like she's gonna try and track her
down and for my money Arya will kill her
and I'm gonna call it right now she's
gotta kill her in the dark cuz when are
you blew that can't Allah's in total
blackness my first thought is she knows
how to fight in blackness she learned to
fight blind can that other girl fight
blind
that stuff was definitely the highlight
of the episode some other stuff that was
not quite as great but was still
interesting the stuff with the high
Sparrow and all that going on this guy
he's oh he's good and I'm really curious
I can't call myself whether or not I
think Marjorie has actually bought into
all this or if she's playing the game
because she sells it really well when
she brings Toman in but at the same time
I know she is really good at that and I
remember just an episode ago so one of
two things happen either seeing her
brother in that state finally broke her
and she did actually cave and she was
being legit or just made her all the
more devious about what she's doing I
could see that going either way tolman I
I think he has actually drank the
kool-aid on this I think she did her job
a little too well but so but seeing all
that pan out and play out it's it's
really interesting and it puts the
Lannisters and the Tourelles in a really
uncomfortable situation because very
clearly the people of the city are all
in favor of this joining of the crown
and the faith but that's not in the
interest of any of the houses the stuff
with generis was fine it was a you know
kind of a reminder of where she's
heading but you know it's it's not
they're not giving us more stalls or
actually got I heard you she gets her
dragon she's got an army she's gonna go
collect your other armies awesome great
but I mean overall this episode is eight
step down from previous episodes the
last one especially was phenomenal this
one it's not bad but it's not what that
one was there is one segment of this
thing though that was just Oh God Samuel
and his family and that dinner oh god
that was painful I mean I'm not big on
awkwardness like in a scene like less
milk how awkward and uncomfortable this
is I don't enjoy watching that as a rule
of thumb and that's what this scene was
and it feels kind of unnecessary because
i bought everything that Sam told us
about his dad we didn't need this big
ass long awkward scene just to
reemphasize all the stuff we had already
been told and as far as Gilly saying you
know when we went down to Castle bike
the incident she said that I might well
he's gonna pick up on that and he did so
I mean the whole thing was predictable
and it's just as well that they got out
there because if Sam's dad actually
taking a close look at that kid he would
have gone wait a minute that kids blonde
with blue eyes you're not blonde with
blue eyes you're not blonde with blue
eyes there is no way that that is my
grandchild so probably just as well that
they're leaving although you know all
that said I do kind of like the payoff
that Sam well in his own meek little way
get some balls takes the sword leaves
man's up many can't man up in the
traditional way actually stand up to his
father it's not in him but he's got a
man up in what is the best way that he
himself can actually do that you know
what good on you Sam but overall that
segment just sort of yeah I'm in there
the-- episode as a whole kind of had a
little bit of a predictable feel i mean
not that I could call absolutely
everything that was happening but like i
said i called that that was benjin right
off the bat that whole dinner scene I
figured what was going on there was
nothing particularly surprising about De
Niro stuff I was slightly surprised by
some of the stuff with the high Sparrow
and the walk of atonement that didn't
happen it's not a filler episode it is
moving things forward but it's just you
know it's it's a it's a slowing down
from what we've got in the last couple
of episodes so hopefully steam will get
picked up again next time on one final
note two episodes in a row with no
ramsey i'm i'm liking this streak how
far could we take it so blood of my
blood have you seen this episode what
did you think about it whatever it is
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter I
council of geeks follow the council
geeks podcasts on iTunes and stitcher
and until next time this council isn't
churned